often it is either food or the things I need
for example when we go shopping
first a whole cart was 80 euros or 100 euros
but now a whole cart is 200 euros
or even say more MBOs
that students are more likely to experience poverty
due to the high prices
the MBO council therefore wants the cabinet and the municipalities
students who have difficulty making ends meet
going to help
many MBO schools are already trying to support their students
students get at the zadkine in rotterdam
this week two coupons to redeem
at school we try them a little bit
to give a helping hand by
come to school with a receipt
and actually get something
what they need at that time
think of lunch
think of a meal
maybe also think of a dentist visit
we can offer such examples ourselves
of students
for students
there is also a special budget coach at school
that gives students tips to deal better with money
very nice everyone
the students think
but other students should also,
according to them
be helped
I would appreciate it
if several schools had this